more heavy artillery enters to dance
Capital hartum brought in by the Army to
use in battles against the paramilitary
rapid support forces the battle for
control of Sudan shows no sign of ending
[Music]
in this video released by the Army one
of the senior commanders and member of
the ruling sovereignty council is seen
greeting troop members it comes a day
after Sudan's Army Chief Abdel fattah
al-burhan inspected troops at the Army
headquarters in hartum in a rare public
appearance for the general his third
since the conflict began in mid-april
[Applause]
and on the same day Army supporters
demonstrated in Port Sudan their
demanding United Nations Envoy Volker
parties leave accusing him of
interference
we demand that volca the UNM boy be
removed from his position he is
responsible for the conflict because he
has contributed to the division and
separation of the people in this country
both of the Army and the rapid support
forces have claimed control of strategic
sites in Khartoum this week
[Music]
and both insist they have the upper hand
air strikes continue in hartum along
with heavy artillery fire in residential
areas Street battles have also occurred
in many parts of the capital destroying
homes and properties
the two sides have been holding indirect
talks in the Saudi city of Jeddah since
the beginning of the month but they fail
to agree on a permanent resolution a
series of ceasefires have failed
statement gives a statement that the
truce will be from this hour to that
hour the continued Air Raids and
artillery fire is proof that there is
more than one decision maker in this
crisis and it's one of the reasons that
the hostilities don't end it proves the
lack of Will from the Sudanese Army
and for Sudanese more stalt negotiations
mean more uncertainty and more suffering
people are leaving cartoon because
there's no food no water no electricity
and there is very high levels of
insecurity wfp is providing hot meals
wfp will continue to support refugees as
and when they arrive but the future is
very Bleak for those people it is Bleak
for Sudan and it is Bleak for the region
more than a month into the conflict the
U.N says one million people have been
displaced they can't go home until the
two sides agree to stop fighting Heber
Morgan Al Jazeera cartoon